hey kids it's me kevin smith uh
and i got an announcement for you um you
know i've been working for
mattel and netflix making this masters
of the universe
revelation series that's gonna debut on
the streamer
um i am happy pleased
proud ecstatic really to announce
our composer we scored a composer uh and
he's scoring for us ladies and gentlemen
and that composer is none other
than metal maestro himself the great
bear mccreary
ladies and gentlemen that's right the
man who gave us the score to the wagon
dead
battle star galactica remember those
drums agents of shield
outlander he's doing the score for
masters of the universe
revelation he's working on it right now
and he just sent me
the first cue his past his first pass
the very first queue
of our show which is the transformation
sequence
when prince adam holds the power sword
aloft and says the magic words and
fabulous powers are revealed to him
and he becomes he-man so i'm gonna
listen to it
let's listen to it together man at the
same time
uh what you're gonna hear right at the
top of it before bears music kicks in
is perhaps one of the most famous
phrases in
pop culture history uh spoken by our
prince adam slash he-man himself
uh the great christopher woods so here
we go ladies and gentlemen
uh bear goes into the woods let's see
what he comes out with let's check this
out man
[Music]
by the power of grayskull
[Music]
oh come on
i have the power
oh there oh bear
there man look at it well you can't see
it but listen to it
it is perfect perfect
this is the transformation sequence
right here this is where cringer
uh the sword is turned on creature and
he becomes battle cat
[Music]
oh
ladies and gentlemen that that's a first
pass by a genius i
like i can't wait
by the power of grayskull man that is
fantastic bear mccreary
is our composer ladies and gentlemen the
show is called masters of the universe
revelation and will be out in 2021 on
netflix